the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden was on MSNBC
yesterday and uh well earlier in the
week he said that Putin has lost the war
in Iraq but that was not his worst flub
because watch what happened as they
tried to go to commercial free America
where they voted for me or not well and
and the ones that didn't vote for your
bills but run on them
Mr President thank you thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here we'll have reaction and
Analysis to everything we just heard
from the
guys he makes Mr Burns look like Andrew
tank like this is just
Douglas how much longer can this charade
go on I mean this show it just does not
stop and apparently he's running again I
love the host saying don't go anywhere
yeah uh you
find his way out in the studio
um look I mean it it in some ways one
has to be careful about this because
it's getting into sort of elder abuse
territory at the moment the whole
Democratic party hierarchy is see what
you like about the Republican party
which goodness knows has its own
problems but it doesn't lack uh Talent
beneath the top level and it doesn't
lack people who know how to talk uh the
Democratic Party by contrast is is led
by somebody who it's just very sad
actually every day now there's another
bidenism uh the reason why he didn't
seem to know the rules of live
television was because he doesn't do it
very often it based on any president
um he uh he he uh he's got the 90 year
old Dan find
admire in many ways a very distinguished
senator in the past from California
wheeled into the Senate recently doesn't
seem to realize that she hasn't been
there
um the Press aren't allowed to speak to
her you've got John fetterman uh the
senator
um from Philadelphia who who was at by
the I-95 it was a rebuild the day uh
standing beside Joe Biden he seems
fetterman seemed to refer to Joe Biden
as the collapsed Bridge which
I mean it's not
um and uh and and then you've got Kamala
Harris always on hand to give us a long
disquisition about the nature of time
and and it is very interesting when Owen
Kamal Harris talks about the nature of
time because time slows down
whenever she does so in fact it almost
grinds to a halt
um but yeah I mean the the party's in a
mess and the the the the the Elder
Generation The Binding generation is
holding on my prediction is actually uh
that he's not going to be running
they're gonna get him and camel out and
it's going to be as pleasant as they can
do it but it'll be pretty brutal